let me ask about your your friend your
colleague uh Alan dershowitz and I'll
also ask about your review of his most
recent book but before then it'd be
interesting um
to ask what you think of him as a human
being as a lawyer he's a quite an
interesting case he's represented some
of the most controversial figures in
history including Jeffrey up Steve
including Jeffrey Epstein Mike Tyson
Julian Assange Jim Baker and uh Jeffrey
Epstein and even Donald Trump
so he's an interesting figure what do
you think about that because bobulo
what do you think what do you think
about uh him as a human being as a
lawyer what he represents in terms of
values and ideals well he's a criminal
defense lawyer and the job of a criminal
defense lawyer is to represent the goose
criminals
uh he he he is a lifelong Democrat
he didn't represent Trump because he
agrees with him politically voted for
Hillary I believe you wrote he voted for
Hillary yes that's what he says and I
absolutely believe it he's a he's a
liberal Democrat
um but is a criminal defense lawyer as
well as a professor
and um I've represented some very nasty
people
uh in in my career
um I wouldn't go out for coffee with
them
but they have the constitutional rights
to representation
and you take that very seriously yes you
notice something that people don't
understand about their shorts
he was asked by Trump to represent him
in the second impeachment as well he
turned him down
why do you think he turned down so
people should know he represented Trump
in the first impeachment represented
only in the first
and he was successful in when Trump was
impeached the second time he has to
represent him
Alice had a lifelong policy of only
representing somebody once never twice
why
because he never wanted to be house
counsel to the mafia
and so he early on had this position he
only represented somebody once the mafia
wants a lawyer who's an in-house
Council who represents similar enroll
their cases
so that's the reason that now I never
publicly explained that I know it's the
fact because I've known him from the day
that we met at Harvard Law School 1964
he was a first year Professor I was a
first year student we both had Brooklyn
accents and we hit it off
we've we've been close friends ever
since so there's some kind of unethical
line that's crossed when you
continuously represent a client
yeah he thought it was not so much an
ethical one and you have a right to
represent Mafia people but he didn't
want to be house counselor he didn't
want to be you know have him ask him for
advice in advance of what they were
doing he he was willing to represent
somebody once no matter how awful Klaus
Von Bulow was accused of killing his
wife these are pretty nasty people
um but he didn't want to be house
counsel to any of them